Where's the music?
What?
Is there no music?
Oh, I see the issue!
Give me one second.
Okay, I had to use a different capture for my Elgato.
One second, one second, one second.
You're gonna not hear it in two seconds, three, two, one.
Okay, there you go.
And then I do this.
This.
No!
There we go!
There we go.
Now I can hear it too.
Wait, now it's double!
I forgot my wallet.
I'll toss some money in next time.
Wait, it shouldn't be.
Oh!
I fixed it.
That was weird.
Oh, oh.
OBS changed some like settings.
I can't get a made outfit off my mind.
That I care.
This guy.
Wait a second.
I didn't start the game.
Did I accidentally press go?
Why are we following Healy Jewel Osmond?
Welcome back, everybody.
What is he doing?
Welcome back to Tomodachi Live.
Not that I care.
Welcome back, welcome back.
Welcome back.
Because he's your favorite.
No!
Keep your friends close and your enemies closer.
That is the situation happening here.
Some me's are gathering somewhere.
Oh, probably in the center.
We...
Before we get started on too much, let's...
Let's check out our clothes for today.
Horse costume!
The red dress!
Wait a second, you're so right.
I love the Western.
This needs to go to Frog Bird, I think.
It's like a real Western outfit.
I like this like school uniform Oh, I love it in the pink
Oh, I love it in the blue Oh my god, the pants are mint I
love it in the gray I love it in the brown
We need all We will create us a lot today And one other me
that I wanted to have I wonder I'm big boss Maybe we can
just make naked snake What if heaven Snake looks so similar,
though.
Wait, that could cause, like, some drama.
Let's check out our food.
Welcome.
So I already bought these.
I'll buy them again, though.
We're still on the hunt to find somebody's favorite or least
favorite food ever, ever, ever.
Riden, yeah, we can do Riden.
And I also made a new food.
Let's see.
Oh, hold on.
Let me, I made a new food.
Rations!
We'll buy some rations.
Thank you very much.
It's tough to find the most favorite.
We made some rations.
Let's check out our new...
Welcome.
New products have been added.
Indoor wedding set?
And garden wedding set?
They're so expensive.
Wait, what's the weekly special?
Ice rink.
I guess I'll buy it.
Thank you very much.
Is it because...
We had the meat...
I almost said Sims.
Oh my gosh.
ViviCore, thank you so much for the vibe.
Get there!
Is it because...
We had some meats get married.
They just want to have their wedding again and again and
again inside as well.
You unlock those after the wedding.
Please come again.
Ah, well, also, let's check out the news.
Who lives in the white void?
Minto has done something amazing.
What?
What has Minto done?
What would happen if you put a pocket watch on top of a
pocket watch?
She's amazing!
She's so impressive!
These are questions that no one is asking.
I love the intro video, it's fun to watch.
Thank you, Thaddeus.
You might want to take a few steps back from the park.
I built it for size, not stability.
For size, not stability.
Oh, yeah, what do you have to say about this?
This is bad news for everyone.
Thanks for watching!
Peace to peace!
The bone zone has a problem, but also...
Minto is doing something.
Minto is...
daydreaming, maybe.
I think that's Pliskin.
Oh, he's...
I know I'm head over heels, but...
Now I'm literally seeing...
Oh, my mama got married.
She was very confused.
Why would you tell her that?
Oh my god, I can't stand these guys anymore.
They're driving me insane.
Phoebe?
I bought something for Phoebe I thought was perfect for her.
Oh, Phoebe, are you okay?
Something on your mind.
Let me give it to her real quick.
Watch this.
Wait, I did buy it, right?
No, I didn't.
Hold on, Phoebe.
I'll be right back.
Look at this.
Wait, maybe it's a daily special.
Not bad.
Look, it's just a Phoebe hair.
Phoebe hair clip.
Also, I need to get the triceratops hood.
So cute.
I know.
I love the building suit.
as well.
Baggy, striped, long sleeve, tee.
I need to give this to Kiwawa.
Let's see.
Oh.
This guy is also going to be daydreaming about Minto, and
he's not going to do freaking anything about... I can't
do...
I can't deal with these guys anymore.
Store is stacked.
It's this one again.
Wait for me.
Try and catch me.
I'm gonna eat oh my god oh i'm so scared so scared so scared
so scared so scared
the absolute will they won't they it's it's painful i want
to be sweethearts it's painful it's painful they're yearning
so much and don't act on it when when will it happen um
let's give that to Phoebe real quick though before I forget
oh that's not food wait actually let's give Phoebe some
sushi dream echo why can't we have dreams like that brain
that was a daydream that was a daydream you can daydream
anything you want want.
Sushi is pretty good.
Let's do our expressions, the ohachi.
When greeting.
I also made some things besides the food, which I would like
to give to people.
Ohachi.
I'm happy.
Yeah, perfect.
You want it?
I missed though the days that you used to be able to like
throw the stuff and they would like walk over.
They would walk over and get it.
All right.
Thank you.
Bye-bye.
The memes on your island are living such vibrant and
fulfilling lives.
Phototomo photography?
Well!
Here!
What do you think?
Exactly!
I forgot the hair clip again, you're right.
We interrupt to bring you some breaking news.
Here's what's happening on our island.
Anyone who finally wants to see what they look like will be
excited to learn to see what they look like.
A premiere photo studio has opened up on Yei.
Yei?
Gets Dron Jerome.
Welcome back away to Dron.
Island residents can stop and for a quick photo shoot, which
is kind of like a selfie that someone else takes for you.
These photos can be saved to your system or deleted if you
catch someone at a bad angle.
Never.
I always get the good side.
There are no mirrors.
That's because they're portals to hell.
All right.
Wait, Minto, come here.
No!
Okay, actually, Snake works too.
What's wrong with you?
Um...
Hey...
Good afternoon...
Are you hungry?
Something new to wear!
You know...
Something new to wear.
Cameras just steal your soul.
Maybe he wants something to feel more confident in.
I'll get you something.
Let's
go to the shop.
Tuxedo?
You guys are crazy.
Wanting a tuxedo.
We even have...
Oh, we do!
Well, it's a suit.
Oh, it's a business suit.
We could still do it though.
It works.
We'll do the suit.
The business suit.
Hmm.
What's the difference between a suit and a tuxedo, actually?
I have no idea.
He likes it.
The bow tie.
Tuxedo is more formal.
Yeah, but like they look the same, no?
Bow tie and cut.
But I thought you see sometimes tuxedo that have a tie like
that.
There's satin finishes in spots.
Oh, whoops, not quirk.
I wanted to do an expression.
Let's do when greeting.
What if he says...
Kept you waiting, huh?
That's his greeting.
And it goes...
Oh my gosh, what if he says it when confessing?
How?
That is it, but what?
Captuating, huh?
Capt- oh.
Ha.
The accent doesn't suit him at all, but it's so perfect,
it's so funny.
Captuating, ha?
I always wanted to say that.
I hate to brag, but I do it anyway.
He does it anyway.
Oh my god, he's...
Oh, we'll let him do that.
Yeah, Phoebe's hair clip.
There she is.
Phoebe, you don't wear the hat anymore.
We're gonna give you...
This hair clip is the perfect thing for you ever.
Of course she loves it, of course she loves it.
Yes!
All right.
Let's see what is happening in here.
Hello?
Hi, Blue.
What's wrong?
That is sad.
I'd love to play around with what's missing.
What's missing?
I don't know what this is.
What's missing from the picture?
Guess before you run out of time.
Okay.
There's your first picture.
So what's missing from here?
Three.
Two.
What's missing us?
Take it to all my shirt.
What?
Why is it missing?
pictures so what's missing from here somebody's birthday
it's a it's a it's a spoiler
skill issue happy birthday
fudge i don't know probably rice i think i got it wrong no i
was i was panicking You know, some places in the UK say tea
to me in the evening meal dinner?
What should I have for tea?
Oh, I panicked!
You should have...
I can't get your watcher!
Ibu.
No, Ibu!
You would give me the real prize.
You wouldn't do that to me.
You would give me the...
Oh, yeah.
By the way, they're like...
Do you see this?
very in love and soulmates i hate these guys i hate these
guys greetings canada i want to be friends with ganga oh
okay but ganga is not interested i want to see what happens
i want to see what happens sucking life energy got it i'll
go talk life yeah he loves that he loves that i forgot
greetings canada hey haze because we're happy together heya
gangar do you feel like talking about sucking life energy
sure cool well i have to say he sucks all the energy from
the room i've been super into sucking energy lately after
you got married but wouldn't you rather be wet t-shirt
contest than sucking life energy oh oh i suppose that's true
for some people are you is he getting called out for being a
fake fan oh nothing oh no i don't think he's interested in
sucking life energy oh he's sad I tried chatting with Gengar
about sucking life energy, but we just did not see it the
same way, eh?
Just the way the banana feels, I guess.
Oh, he likes Gengar so much.
Well, that's his only other person that he knows, so...
Oh, he's gonna consult the toilet paper.
Aw, poor Frogbert.
Frogbert needs some more friends.
Let's introduce him to some more people.
Um...
Let's introduce him to...
Oh.
Oh, wrong place.
My bad.
Yeah, Frogborn needs to meet more people.
You need to go out and explore the world.
Let's take him.
Come here, come here.
Alright, come here.
Vicky is drawing...
It's so quiet.
Listen to say it.
Who else is around?
Uh, nobody else is really around.
Okay, that's fine.
In it?
Something about...
Oh, she says.
Try Phoebe.
Sorry.
What?
Wait, what are you doing?
No, no, no.
Here, me, me, Vicky.
There we go, there we go.
Sorry.
No!
He will...
He's one of those types of people that goes like...
You know, when like...
Oh, I'm sorry.
Me?
He's one of those types of people that's just like...
That does like really dramatic sighs so that people will be
like, what's wrong?
Here, you want a Salisbury steak?
Yeah.
Yeah, we'll try rubbing his head.
That's a good idea, too.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
He eats his affairs.
Oh, he liked them.
Vague poster.
Oh, good!
It worked!
Alright, now he can talk to people.
Wait, she wants to talk to you!
Hey, nice to meet you.
I'm Frogbert.
Hey, Frogbert.
I'm Victoria the Hedgehog, innit?
Getting familiar?
But he's bosoms and she...
And she is butt.
Can- can bosoms and butts be pals?
Is that is that possible?
They're like mine.
I mean, they're cut from the same cloth.
They can be friends.
Your mama's house.
Yeah.
Oh, I want to give.
Oh, I got to show you.
Oh, I like boo.
I forgot the cake.
Here's your first picture.
So what's missing from here?
The hourglass glass.
Three.
Rice.
Two.
What's missing is...
Rice.
Why is the gum that color?
Next up, your second picture.
So what's missing from here?
Three.
Two.
One.
What's missing is...
Panini.
And finally...
And finally, Thomas Flavor doing the...
So what do we see from here?
Three, two, one...
She's a guide to the sexy timeline!
Wait, I think that's there.
No!
Hey, you can't win.
I think I'm not very good at this game, you guys.
One of them can be overheard whispering about hiding the
existence of the weak-looking elastic rope from the world.
No, no.
Okay.
I did mention that I made some things.
I might have made a figure.
And I might have made a dogen.
Thank you very much.
The classic.
Let's get to the what?
The streaming house.
Oh, this is a new one!
You fall.
Oh!
Cooking show, cooking show, cooking show.
Uh...
Maybe I'm going out.
Oh, no.
We got a UFO!
Oh, uh, what's up?
Let's give him some food.
Some barbecue, we'll wake you up.
Yum.
Holy cow!
Oh my god!
Oh, he loved it!
Wait a minute, I need to know what is the plot of Isakai to
the second- to the redacted timeline!
Even it's like a quetzalcoatless.
He is a quetzalcoatless.
He is quetzalcoat.
I'm gonna give you guys the sexy book.
I'll give it to you.
Oh wait, book.
Eh?
Why isn't it under book?
the stuff that i made here you go you gave him you said card
to the sexy timeline approved
approval approval i didn't give enough sleep last night oh
no oh okay my island minto is so cute just like iro what do
you mean I've been putting this off.
Yeah, baby.
So close.
We're at level 17.
That's crazy.
So...
What's some of the spring stuff?
There are these lanterns that are cute.
Consolation prize for your Minto, our cutest ghost man of
all dimension.
Don't get discouraged because you did your best.
in a hardened minigame.
Mobius, are you making fun of me?
Thank you for the super child.
Thank you!
I want to give street dancing to somebody.
I want to see...
Vicky's street dancing.
I want to see her breaking it down.
You...
you doing here?
What are you guys doing?
Wait, we could get some photos together.
We'll do a group.
Oh, oh, security, thank you so much for the fifth!
They gave the thing!
Wait, I think I missed it.
Wait, did I miss another fifth?
They gave it?
Thank you so, so much!
Flower!
Oh my gosh, I'm so so so much thank you for the 50 gift
thank you let's do a backdrop oh what is going on here wait
this is kind of funny wait a second actually did they have
something else wait this is just uh this is den set to
channel make Vicky or Vicky the one with the head?
Swap spot.
No!
Oh, yeah, there we go.
There we go.
Oh, wait.
But I...
Any Opo slots will be filled.
No select?
Wait, so if I click confirm, what happens?
Oh, good!
Yeah!
It's a 10 sets of Wait, let's do another one.
Everybody, everybody together.
Oh, oh, wait.
Backdrop.
What is this?
Oh, oh.
Here, I'll let you guys live your dreams.
I'll let you guys live your dreams.
How do you feel?
Wait, what's...
Oh!
Wait, a mystery.
Mystery.
Why are you so sad?
That's good.
Yay!
Oh, oops.
What else is going on in here?
We got the street dancing The press conference The lot Why
do you look like you're being forced into it So cute We're
heading towards the iceberg Iceberg Dead ahead
How'd you like the photo studio?
Got any pics with cool backdrop?
Speaking of, more backdrops will be added as you play
Anytime you see a new icon on the building They're red Oh
cool!
Wait, that's exciting.
Who?
That's so cool atlas.
Hello Minto!
Hello!
Nice!
I know it does kind of feel like playing with the holes.
I've been taking a lot of walks lately, but the paths don't
really go where I want them to.
Oh, okay.
Then we built some paths between my place and other spots
around the island.
Where are you trying to go?
Show me your route?
Oh yeah, you have no road.
That's fair.
Yeah, you have no road.
Yeah, that's understandable.
It will cost three dollars.
Do we have the budget for that right now?
Ah, that's pretty tough.
Three dollars?
You're asking for a whole lot, man.
I'm on it.
Let's get going.
What's funny is right now, I'm eating Jurassic Park gummies.
They don't have any Ketzel Kuala Lash in it, though.
All done.
They do have the most to store, though.
You're going to street dance 101, baby.
Da-da-da.
Yeah.
Jurassic Park gummies.
I'll check it out, ladies.
Actually, sorry.
They're Jurassic World.
My bad.
Why does the Terraso I need a road, though?
Very sus.
You're kind of right.
Why?
Guys!
In public?
Somebody said hi to this sexy timeline.
My heart is racing.
No...
Ew, go home!
This guy is a freak!
You're such a freak!
You're such a pervert!
You're a pervert reading this out loud!
In public!
Mito's right there!
She walked away because she's so disturbed.
I'm gonna give her the Koharu figure.
Oh, ain't my way, boo.
I'm gonna give her...
Let's go how to figure.
She wants a copy.
Look how cute it is.
This is not me.
Guys, I don't think this is me.
I love it if you made me some clothes at the Palette House
Workshop.
I don't think this is me.
Pardon me.
Could I have a moment?
Must be a...
Yeah, maybe it's bootleg.
Hot calling the kettle freak.
What do you mean?
You should give Boo that box of tissues.
Is she just like cringy?
Where freaks takes one to no one.
Yay!
Oh,
he moves spots.
Wait, no, what do you mean to people are gathering?
here wait a second who's coming over
shinsular thank you so much for that why do you have to
thank you surely not Phoebe okay good she's walking out of
the way who is who is coming over
look they're hanging out
oh they're explaining to this I boot wait They're explaining
this, Michael.
He's a really big bunny.
Oh, if it isn't Mickey.
Oh, is it if it isn't Mickey?
Wait,
I keep trying to get the close-up.
Maybe.
Okay, I think I got it.
Oh, it's so funny.
Ah, if it isn't Minky.
He's acting like he's acting like if, oh, what if I pretend
that I fell?
What if she notices and then asks if I'm okay?
Time to get my BBL.
You guys need a big, big bite to survive!
This dogen played me like a damn fiddle!
I'm crying!
Oh,
they're like...
They're like...
This is so...
Oh my goodness gracious.
What's... What is he doing?
I'll never get used to the sight of Minky in person.
She's right there!
Oh no!
Gosh, please, somebody save them.
It's Phoebe.
I love the sea.
She's yelling into the sea.
The sea.
How is it so bad?
Oh gosh.
What is this guy's problem?
It's so bad.
He forgot he wasn't in the box.
I want to try what he said.
Ah no!
I like a beautiful building.
Let's see.
How is it going?
Is
that Haley Jalazman?
What is he doing over here in the shadows?
Good.
Okay.
Holy cow.
Oh, he's breaking it down.
Oh!
Whoa!
In the grass!
He looks like a Pokemon.
Wait.
What are you doing in the grass?
Why are you doing it like that?
Ooh.
Freak island.
Next gen bitchy.
Also, this is so funny.
Oh, look at all the books.
Oh my god.
All the books.
And the figure.
And...
What was that?
Oh, he's just going for it.
And the eye blue, so cute.
We can always make...
Oh!
What's happening?
Ultra friends!
What's going on?
Oh man, big sheep!
Did you hear about the skin?
The skin?
I did.
But did you hear all the talk about a big, big bug?
Oh, yeah.
I heard about that a while ago but you know what we never
finished talking about the main outfit oh that discussion is
different than the one we were having about the beautiful
bosom right totally different anyway as I was saying what is
happening why are they oh they're reminiscing about sad
memories with tears in their eyes why are they in sepia
Mr. Um...
Hernka?
Do you have a moment?
Sad filter.
What's up?
I would just love it if there were a round street lamp right
here.
I'll help you.
To confess?
Where are you gonna put this?
Oh, that doesn't really go right there.
Oh yeah, I love the look of that round street lamp.
Oh yeah, oh yeah, I love the look of that round street lamp.
Right on the sand.
Is he just going to keep turning it on and off?
Oh.
Oh, he's really happy about it, actually.
I think before we get any more, we can...
Oh, now he's doing it literally in the middle of town.
You guys, you are such a freak!
You are such a freak!
Oh my god!
That look of euphoria on your face!
You are such a pervert doing it in the middle of town!
Go home!
You know he's reading the good stuff.
He can't put it down!
This is ridiculous.
Shall we make Ocelot?
Takes one to no one.
Which Ocelot do we make?
Probably young Ocelot.
I should have been the one to fill your dark soul with a
lot.
Should we make Dante?
That Ibu was literally me.
Young, I agree.
Dante from the Devil May Cry series?
He needs like a big old yaoi chin.
At least that's how he looks in Delta.
But he doesn't look so much like that in the original.
He looks more like...
He's so chiseled.
Which Dante though?
Two.
I kind of want to give him the chiseled chin though, you
know?
I kind of want to give him it though
How his hair is like kind of going to be How do you guys
see?
It's like Okay She's like a blonde but But I joined so hard
And got so far Rip my grandma Kaboom Cabal It's like very
blight bright blonde yeah it's like it's like almost like
this that well i don't know if it's just the filter he's
like a platinum my my my guy definitely goes to the salon
and gets that done the blightest stop stop don't make fun of
me in the mgs3 filter his hair is definitely this color
oh my god they gave him the fade
This is such anime hair.
It's so good.
He
needs a little flippy.
This is such a cute hairstyle.
Oh my goodness.
I like this one, JLo.
Oh, it's so close.
Wait!
This is it, I think.
Teihaji?
so bad looking though.
But it's like it, but it's bad.
I wonder if we should...
This is too spiky.
The back of his hair different.
Oh.
We can make him look like my twin.
I think that's a fake Minto.
I think maybe we need to make the real Minto.
I mean, some of you guys have been saying that.
She doesn't look like me anyway, so...
Oh, here we go.
Here we go.
Oh.
Maybe adding ears will help.
Oh, true.
I don't know why they don't come default with ears.
It's kind of funny.
Oh, his ears are definitely...
Oh, yeah.
I think it looks better.
Okay.
How can I make one eyebrow raised?
Is it even possible?
Is it even possible To make one eyebrow raise Unless we do
it like We
have to try Oh We need it Oh I think
I had it like this Maybe you can paint it on True True We'll
paint on his eyebrows Oh, good, good.
Yeah, that's a good idea.
Good thinking, good thinking.
Oh, gosh.
That's a jump scare every time.
I don't know what eyes to give him.
Actually, I don't...
I think Ocelot has lower eyelashes, too, But definitely
Ryden has them the most.
Ryden has crazy lower lashes.
That guy is so fabulous.
So beautiful.
Hmm.
I think maybe...
Okay, maybe...
Hold on.
I think I got it.
There was another...
Oh, this one is the one I was thinking.
Either these or the other ones.
I always knew Ocelot painted those eyebrows.
You need a picture for reference?
Okay, hold on.
I can get you.
He is this or this?
He's always...
Hmm.
Hold on, let me save a picture for you.
Oh my gosh, this is so high...
This is...
This is so...
Wow.
Duh.
So high death.
Whoa!
And then imagine with the eyebrows, right?
Imagine with the eyebrows.
Actually, I think this one works better.
Holy jawline.
That's what I'm saying.
Maybe we need to make it more square.
We need to make it more square after all.
But everything gives them just a ginormous...
Oh!
No, it needs to be...
Square.
Squarer.
Oh, no!
Everything's too round!
Chins a lot.
What if...
Okay, with the eyes...
Hold on.
I think my issue was like...
They're not squinty enough, but...
Oh!
That!
Where he's just like...
You know?
I honestly feel like this nose...
No, this nose.
I feel like this one works the best for him.
My man does need some cheekbones.
That
looks good.
Yeah, the eyebrows...
The eyebrows, we gotta wait until the eyebrows.
But of course...
My guy's got something on his lips.
Something is going on there.
We got the ears.
Oh, I was going to draw this on myself, but I don't think we
need to.
Um...
I don't think I...
He looks like...
He looks like Sniper Wolf with the lipstick.
I'm taking it off.
This is too perfect, maybe.
This might be too perfect!
Wait, was there anything else?
He doesn't really have any stubble or anything.
He's so clean-shaven.
Some definition to his eyes.
We'll go with the lighter one.
Alright, let's draw his eyebrows.
Let's draw his eyebrows.
We'll go with like a lighter brown.
Yeah.
Hold on, I need to get the mocks a lot of reference.
Okay, I gotta...
It honestly, it looks too much like...
I'll try again.
I think probably this eyebrow will be easier.
I want it a little more.
Let's...
Let's see.
Color range.
My name is Revolver White.
Yo!
She has more like a...
Like that, you know?
Oh!
So close.
Wait, hold on.
What is...
I haven't tried smoothing.
I want to see what it looks like, though.
Oh, interesting.
Paint behind.
Yeah, okay.
What do you guys think?
I'm gonna...
Oh, wait.
I'm gonna redo the first one.
This one.
What will we do?
We'll make it a little bit more dramatic.
Oh, oops.
I messed up.
Okay, hold on.
Oh, there it is!
Ah!
You genuinely nailed this Ocelot boss?
Thank you.
Oh, Charlie!
Charlie, Bravo!
Oh my god, it's been forever!
Whoa, it looks amazing.
The white hair with the minty tips, the blue eyes, pigtails,
and the cute shirt.
Very pretty lady.
Johnny Bravo!
I've missed you!
Sorry, Snake, you might have missed your chance with Vito.
I think he's taller than Snake, though.
I can't remember.
Ocelot.
My name is Ocelot.
Hello, Minto, and Le Chat.
How goes everyone today?
Hello, I'm great.
Welcome back, Mogcelot.
Mission complete now.
Oh, I'm...
Well, we don't have big boss on the island.
We have a solid snake.
Yeah, snake will call him a damn scut.
But should he be Revolver Ocelot?
I didn't really, I guess at this time he was not Revolver.
He's just Aus a lot.
Shalashaska.
Yeah, I'm big boss.
I'm big boss.
Adamska will definitely be his nickname.
Everybody's at risk.
What is his birthday?
When's your birthday?
Oh, I saw a lot.
June 6th.
That's kind of soon.
Is that actually?
June 6th.
That's what the Google AI says though, is it right?
Oh,
D-Day.
Oh, yeah!
yeah all right six oh what age do we make him wait how old
is he in okay hold on wait how old is he in virtuous mission
okay if and in 1944 he was born 1944 he was born oh my gosh
wait 20 okay you guys do the math for me 64 minus 44 thank
you oh my gosh you guys are so smart my name is Ocelot it's
nice to meet you my name is Ocelot my name is Ocelot It's
nice to meet.
My name is Ocelot.
It's nice.
It's nice to meet you.
Today is April.
My name is Ocelot.
It's nice.
It's not.
My name is Ocelot.
It's nice to meet you.
Today is April 28th, 20th.
My name is Ocelot.
It's not...
It's nice to meet you.
Yeah, Josh Keaton pitched.
I know I'm like...
Today is April 28th, 2026.
So, how does this voice sound?
My name is Ocelot.
I think this might be...
It's nice to meet you.
Today is April 28th, 20th.
My name is Ocelot.
It's nice to meet you.
Today is April 28th, 2026.
So, my name is Ocelot.
It's nice to meet you.
My name is Ocelot.
We'll just go normal.
It's nice to meet you.
Movement?
He's fast.
Honest.
His energy?
It varies.
His thinking is very serious.
And overall, he's the most, he's one step away from being
over quirky.
A buy the book straight talker puts a premium on results.
A determined self-starter cuts their own path, letting
nothing stand in their way.
Quick to execute plans.
Alright, you guys are gonna have to move because Ocelot
needs to live here.
I'm next door!
Hey, you must be big boss.
It's nice to meet you.
My name is Ocelot.
I'm an ambitious maverick.
freaking out right now i want to experience everything this
world has to offer i live life on my own terms and try to be
my own me thanks in advance for looking after me here
he stole her house you live with frogbert now you moved away
his energy varies but it's dependent on if snake has tackled
him or he's thinking about snake or a snake is in the room
of course i decide to slack off during work To tune in and
she's making us a lot.
I'm looking for a super niche hobby.
Something only I understand.
Torture!
He's probably hungry.
Would you like...
Mmm...
Would you like some barbecue?
Yum.
Oh yeah, I liked it.
Such a good face.
He looks too good.
Oh, I don't know how to
put him on
my...
Wee, wee, wee, wee,
wee.
Okay, I leave.
We interrupt to bring you some breaking news.
We've just received some breaking news.
The vibe?
Wait, what does this mean?
Now that the island is home to 10 residents, we've received
a report of the island in 5.
What's the vibe?
This represents the overall state of the island.
Uh-oh.
What does that mean?
At this time, yay!
Get Strangeroan.
Get Strangeroan?
Welcome back away, Toma and Sideran.
S5 has been established as Pushy Island.
What is Pushy Island, man?
Thanks for watching!
Vibe check time!
I'm Snake, and you're up to date!
What does pushy mean?
Congrats on reaching 10 residents of your island right now!
The place is giving off pushy island vibes!
What does that mean?
Of course that's based on the Mias who live here now, so the
island vibe could change as you add new residents.
Not
all you'll find under island info though, you can see the
lingo.
Yeah, how many ponderings you've resolved.
So much stuff about...
Yay!
Staggy Strangero!
My islanders are pushy!
What does that mean?
Why are you watching him closely?
Wait!
What's happening here?
They're confessing that the line everyone was in disbelief
got them all.
Oh, yeah, when I made the book, they were like, what's a
line that would be in the book?
And it was everyone was in disbelief.
What is he doing standing there?
Oh, my God.
Snake, back up.
We have a new wish we can get, so.
What should we do?
the music is so creepy does anyone else think that oh wait
we can do appetite set what's this anyone with the appetite
big or small big eater or light eater oh wait would that
help with if I want to Feed them more or not.
Let's try it.
Nice.
Oh, they're hopping together.
Oh, we have a new ticket.
Uh-oh.
We interrupt to bring you some breaking news.
Hey, I'm made.
Thank you.
I'm gonna find a good day.
Kyoto Tour.
Kyoto Tour!
And one resident is quoted as saying, I hope my roommate is
gifted a trip soon.
I could really use the alone time.
It looks like a wish has already been added.
If someone can leave immediately, stop by the wishing
fountain to learn more.
Thanks for watching.
I'm Victoria the Hedgehog and you're up to date.
Very nice.
Oh, Kyoto?
And then we can do Latin America!
Wait, there's so many.
Holy cow.
Who's going to Kyoto?
Who would he take?
I wonder.
Surely this time.
I don't think so.
I don't know.
I'm gonna give it to Minto this time.
Minto has not been able to go.
Let's try.
Are you really giving me a Kyoto tour?
I've never been to Kyoto.
Time to pack my best.
This is new for me.
This selfish?
To get Sukyo Bridge, it's straight out.
No, it's blocked, Chris.
Say cheese.
You're there too!
Wait, but I thought...
I thought Mito and Aibu were like best as friends.
Wait, this is so cute though.
No, Simonji's really lighting up the night.
Say cheese.
I like the photos.
Gengar's a good travel buddy.
Clearly.
What do I get?
Why didn't you take Ibu?
I even got you this souvenir.
Always the tag along, never the broad.
Mahatsa, thank you.
Oh, Ibu went down to good friends and Gengar's ultra
friends.
It's all of the...
I think it's all of the rituals they've been doing.
Probably.
She really liked it.
I will try sushi!
You guys got demoted, no way.
Just a like, just a like.
Nothing beats pizza.
Okay, so now we got this.
Can eat a lot without getting full.
Small portions are enough to fill them up.
I am a light eater, so I think I'll do this one, actually.
I'm a little.
That's my quirk.
Pitzer.
The best pitzer in all of London.
I feel a bit more like myself.
But for someone like Snake, we can give him a lot.
Oh, six?
Oh?
Oh my god.
Everybody?
Stay calm?
Oh my god.
Wait.
I have to see what Gengar's is first though.
Welcome to the home of Joe Mama's house.
I think Big Big B and Snop would be best friends.
Oh good.
Yeah I agree.
What should we talk about to help them get along?
What's something that they could...
I mean, a big, big butt, obviously.
Big, big V.
Yeah, because it's big, big, big butt.
Big, big Vicky likes a big, big butt.
Can't wait for somebody to interrupt Snake's confession and
ruin it.
Just to see your reaction.
No!
I mean, Gengar might.
He might.
Wait, this might distract Snake.
You're right.
Oh, no, wait.
I can't.
Uh-oh.
Oh, no.
I can't.
I can't get out of it.
They can talk about Sabrina Carpenter.
Got it.
Like, ooh.
Oh, no.
I'll go round up the big, big B and snob.
No, it's fine.
It's fine.
We're fine.
Everything's fine.
Everything's fine, everything's fine, everything's fine,
everything's fine, everything's fine.
Snock, say hello to Big, Big B.
Like boo.
Boo.
Big Big B.
This is Snock.
Like boo.
Do you feel like talking about?
Sabrina Carpenter.
Shoo.
Huh.
You know, Snake, getting a good look at you, you kind of
look.
Looks like Sabrina Carpenter.
Oh, wait, what?
Really?
You think so?
That's the first time anyone's ever told me that.
What?
What a compliment.
Hey, do you want to hang out sometime?
I think we could be great friends.
I needed the fan art of, like, Snake dressed up as Sabrina
Carpenter.
He's got her eyes.
She just straight up lying.
Good friends.
Oh, Snake's nickname can be...
We'll just keep it the same.
Snake, how goes it?
Yeah, this is fine.
They talked about Sabrina Carpenter and ended up becoming
friends.
Like...
Boo!
Like Boo!
Go home.
You are busy.
It's back.
It worked.
Minto wants to play a game, though.
We gotta get her not distracted.
I was playing on a double shadow quiz.
Double shadow quiz.
She can't be thinking about shadow quizzes.
What are these?
Ibu?
And a disco ball.
The answer is...
Disco ball and Ibu?
Yes.
Next up, your second mystery double shadow.
What are these?
Keep...
Temporal rice and nochi.
The answer is...
Nope.
I can't even say it right, though.
Making this the filler episode.
Give me my tissues or toilet paper, whatever the... I don't
care.
All right, here we go.
Wait, why is... Wait, what is this, though?
What is Frogbird thinking?
Why are you... Why are you like this?
Noki.
I'm not even sure.
what this feeling you're already married i've been imagining
what life would be like if i boo-boo and i had a child i
dare say my island's gangara is even more cursed might be
not cursed at all what are you talking about be great maybe
wait who's having the baby wait which one is having the baby
there's something about this time of year that's exciting
for me it just feels fresh and new who's having the baby
yes yes yes good all right we'll we'll play Play with Ibu
and then we'll do it.
The confession is here.
Bowling!
Okay.
Throw the ball and knock over all the pins.
Oh!
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry!
No!
Gengar, last go standing.
All right, give me my tissues.
Thank you.
All right.
It's time.
I can't believe it.
Oh my god, he finally, somebody finally summoned the
courage.
I need to clear my head.
Hrnka, I can't hold back my feelings for Minky.
I need to tell her how I feel Go for it Where should I
confess my love?
Where would I want to be confessed to?
The restaurant at the restaurant The I want this place
Island spot I don't know what that means I think we did that
last time Oh yes that's right We got to The cherry blossom
Amidst the cherry blossoms.
Yeah, yeah.
Facing the sea.
Wait.
Did it roll?
There.
Like that.
Yeah, yeah.
Amongst the cherry blossoms.
By his favorite lamp.
Oh, I should have done it there!
Um, um...
I think we did by shouting last time.
Desperately.
I kind of...
I think Snake would be very old-fashioned, though.
I think Snake is an old-fashioned guy.
We could do it with a gift.
A catchphrase!
What kind of catchphrase would express my feelings?
I think I got it.
Hold on.
Snake, solid Snake would never say you're pretty good.
He does not say you're pretty good.
If this were Naked Snake, then yeah.
This technically isn't even Snake's line.
He stole it.
I know Gengar is gonna come in and fuck this up.
And I'm not gonna let his stupid ass ruin this, finally.
Do you think love can bloom?
Okay.
Do you think love can bloom on the battlefield?
Oh!
It worked.
Should I change the one I'm wearing first?
I told you he just needed the confidence!
No, no, no, you look great.
All right.
It's time to side myself up and say how I really feel.
I'm scared.
Do you think love can bloom on the battlefield?
That's it?
That's all you're gonna say?
Huh?
it right there
the one who truly is mince right it's me i'm the one who's
always loved minke even more than life itself mince which of
us do you choose
fluskin i'd love to go out with you yeah phoebe
Oh my god!
We're falling in love!
I think Minky and Pliskin still is fine.
It happened!
And
um...
We'll do this one.
Eat with a guy.
Wait, this is...
Wait.
Big eater.
We'll give him a big eater.
Yeah, big eater.
Oh my god, it happened.
What if I give it to Minto?
Oh, it jumps in.
I was here.
Congrats, it took season 3, but congrats!
Mito had zero hesitation, but she was like sick over Phoebe
very true to life!
It happened!
Oh my god, it happened!
Are you pregnant?
Check the tummy?
Oh, he wouldn't let me check the side?
Do you have a baby bump?
Not that I care, I just heard.
him saying oh my oh what's happening here feby feby had to
go out to eat something yummy after getting rejected i don't
know thank you so much for the tiny gifted notice anything
about me oh i wore my favorite clothes just for him actually
i gave him that outfit and he hated it
you were just wearing whatever you slept in it's rude to
just look at an iphone ask that so i've kind of done that
for these things sequel your favorite color is emerald green
did i do no i won't leave him for anything although actually
no i would leave him the only color i don't like is it i
would leave it for for them to be happy with him for him to
be happy with autograph.
I wanted to mention the five plantains at this restaurant
are so good.
Once you try some, you won't order some anywhere else.
Yeah, sounds good.
Is that so?
I prefer the five plantains recipe my family has handed down
by generations.
I was not aware of that.
Poor guy is trying.
Everybody stay calm.
stay calm i can't believe it happened wait we have a sale oh
nice the afternoon marker welcome hey we're running a
special sale today wait that's even cheaper than when i
bought it earlier i bought it was like 17 before be sure to
stop by again tonight thank we'll be free oh wait what's
happening who's is dreaming!
What does he dream of?
Ah.
Shoot.
Oh.
It was just a dream.
Uh.
What's up?
No wonder!
My heart is racing!
No wonder he was dreaming of it!
You guys need to talk.
You guys need to hang out right now.
Pardon me, could I have a moment?
My name is Ocelot.
Hey, Ocelot.
I'm Andy.
Friends.
Subliminal messaging works.
Oh, Ocelot is important!
Yeah, how important a ration can be!
Yes?
Oh!
Seems like minded!
Thanks for helping me and I will get closer.
Of course.
He needs a friend.
He needed a friend, you guys.
Oh my gosh.
I cannot... Where are they?
Where are the two loved ones?
Where are they?
They're enjoying their restaurant date immensely.
I want to go into Sizeria.
That's right.
I bet Phoebe wants to be friends with us a lot.
Yeah, we got to get us a lot a better fit for sure.
I want to be friends with Victoria's and her child.
Yeah!
What should we talk about?
It never gets old.
The big, big butt.
Got it.
I'll go talk to her about a big, big butt.
It never gets old, the big, big butt.
Hey, uh, Victoria the hedgehog.
Condens!
A big, big butt.
Sure.
I'm in.
wait has there been some kind of news on that front or
something you haven't heard they found an ancient big thing
but here on yay get strong drone what that's supposedly 500
years old no way my reaction really makes you wonder about
what life was like my reaction to that news thanks for
sparking my imagination bb wait like no i don't think i got
it no i don't That book on big, big, but trivia really paid
off.
If you want to hang out, I'd love to tell you more.
Oh, yeah!
Definitely makes me happier, innit?
Noah's Vicky the Hedgehog.
Who's taking photos?
Yay!
Please step my game up.
Good friends!
Fawky!
Um...
We'll do Vicky.
Anyone who becomes friends with her becomes Vicky.
Vicky.
Hey, Vicky.
Long time.
And we can do Pee-Bee.
Pee-Bee.
Pee-Bee, want to hang out?
Nice.
I knew my big days with knowledge would come in handy one
day.
It's so true!
The Pee-Bee's a sharp one.
Yippee!
Oh, he was just there the whole time taking photos of them!
What a weirdo!
Wait, do you think he's okay?
Gengar, how are you feeling?
Um...
Do you have a moment?
What's wrong?
What's up?
I would just love it if there were a bench right here.
Okay.
Sure.
His descent continues.
Nice.
Oh, this is the empty lot?
Or wait, where is this?
That'll make life on this island a million times better.
Like.
Boo.
Oh my gosh, we have the lead number.
Oh, not anymore.
No.
Like.
Boo.
He's just taking photos of Vicky's house.
Something a very normal.
This will be a major snoop.
What?
What are you doing?
You mean a scoop?
She's just a normal person, a normal hedgehog like you and
I.
Actually, last night I discovered a hedgehog live cam where
sometimes hedgehogs just come and hang out.
And sometimes there's a garden mice.
I was watching the hedgehogs on the garden mice.
Pipe guardrail.
Guardrail to keep those pesky pedestrians from walking
wherever they want.
Oh, nice.
Frogbert is a journalist.
Clearly I don't understand his game.
Maybe a beach umbrella.
Wait, what rooms do we have too?
I should probably start giving my me's their own rooms,
right?
I want the graveyard!
I want the grave!
Oh, next level, next level.
Nice.
There.
We'll give this to Ocelot.
I don't think Ocelot would want to live in the camo.
Unless it reminds him of Big Boss.
I thought about it.
I did.
New group.
New backdrop.
What is it?
Oh my god.
What the hell?
This really- this looks like something grandma would post on
Facebook, for real.
So in stream while watching hedgehogs and mice.
They just don't come as often, unfortunately.
It's so cute!
Pets.
Pet backdrop.
What is this one?
Welcome.
Oh, the photo.
Please come again.
We should make a new item.
What should I make, though?
What item should I make?
Where is awesome lot?
My grandma, specifically your grandma's in general.
I think grandma's in general, no?
Oh, renovate.
Here we go.
Your interior is now cat.
Nice.
A revolver?
A drink, yeah!
Of course he loves it.
Oh, dang it, I missed my chance.
No, it's too slow.
This is exactly the kind of room I wanted to live in.
Thank you.
Of course!
Nice.
Nice, very nice.
Welcome.
Please come again.
There we go.
Very nice.
Oh my gosh.
Everybody's...
Wait, what?
What did he say?
They're saying that...
Saying these...
Isakai to the sexy timeline smell like danger.
He is a proud creature.
creature how do you feel snake is the world is the world
more colorful do you feel so do you feel so relieved and
everything do you feel like there's a new skip in your step
and and the breeze is fresher and crisper for that Okay.
Look at you in the zoo!
Look at you there.
When snake moves, I will take a picture.
Yeah, the colors are bright.
Oh,
I got it, I got it, I got it, I got it, I got it, I got it.
There we go.
MNN reminds me of Minky News News.
All right, let's make a new thing then.
Um...
Oh wait, no, I want to...
Wrong thing.
Minky News News!
A treasure.
What should I make?
I made a sexy book.
I made Koharu figure.
Some music?
Oh, we could do music.
Metal Gear Ray, Metal Gear Rex.
We could do...
Snakey.
I'm trying to think of a...
Uh, uh...
Uh...
Um...
Hmm...
Gaspar, you genius.
You're right!
I know what must be made!
I
know what must be made!
We'll smooth it.
Make it easier for me.
Wait, no, too big.
Ears must be a bugger.
Oops.
That's good.
Nope.
It must be that.
It must be the greatest single to ever hit the shelves.
Forever, meow.
I want to be forever.
Do you really want to meow forever?
Endeavor, endeavor.
Endeavor.
I'm gonna write it in a really fancy script too.
Wait, is that real?
Oh, wow, look at that!
That's so crazy!
I don't know you could do that.
Whoa!
the customization I'm not like the most creative person when
it comes to that kind of stuff so the customization people
have been doing is like so insane to me you know I'm like
wow I wish I could ever
I saw someone make a target?
That's crazy!
I want everyone to listen.
I want to be...
Forever...
Do you really want to meow forever?
Endeavor...
We'll do that one on that side.
It's supposed to be like my cat ear outfit, you know?
Well, I am wearing it, but without the cat ears.
Actually, I don't like this pink.
It's too late.
There we go.
That's perfect.
Yeah.
Yes.
Forever, piao.
I want to be forever, meow.
Two years!
Me, Pergun, thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
What do you mean that Ninto and Snake married it?
Oh my gosh, they just got together.
Marriage?
I mean...
I know you guys did it, but like...
I don't know.
They just, they struggled so hard just to confess their own
feelings.
Give them some time.
Give them some time, I think.
To get used to the life.
Okay, this is the cute forever meow single.
Forever.
Forever meow.
Yeah.
All right, let's see.
Content is emotional.
I think, yeah.
And the vibe is...
How would you describe it?
Elegant but dancing.
Or maybe not dancing.
Poppy is so cute.
We'll go with Poppy.
Yeah.
I don't understand the lighting.
It's so funny.
You could have it like...
Oh, lit only at 9 and so...
Wait, that's so awesome.
It doesn't need to be shining, though.
Okay, great.
For
a...
Nice.
Let's go buy it.
Oh, I should...
Whatever.
It's okay.
Everybody needs a forever, meow.
Hey, Ible.
Come here.
Yeah, I am.
Here.
Take it.
Forever meow.
I want to be forever meow.
Why not more than like it?
Look, I don't fight with everyone if that more than I think
what I don't.
Papiche.
This guy yelling into the sea?
I think Victoria the Hedgehog would get a kick out of this
photo.
Oh, okay.
What a strange...
Strange guy.
Phoebe.
Phoebe would do...
Oh, she's knitting.
Or is she?
Yes?
She's doing something?
I must give this to you!
Yes, yes.
Yes, moi moi boo to you too.
Oh, you're full.
Just kidding.
Moi moi boo to you too.
Take.
Take her.
Take this.
She won't hate it.
She's gonna love it.
Who said that?
Gerba?
Pluskin confessed his feelings to me, so I've decided to
jump in and give us a shot.
I'll give it my all.
I think we need to make the real mean, though.
What?
What do you mean you felt a rush of love just now?
From what?
He's enjoying it.
She's self-critical to the max like a certain someone.
Hey, hey!
Wait.
Oh, Ocelot.
Come here.
Oh.
Yeah, come here.
I'm gonna give him two things.
I'm gonna give him...
Did I feed you?
Yes, I did, okay.
I'm gonna give you forever meow.
And I'm also gonna give you something else.
I gave him a forever meow.
Nice.
He seems lonely.
I can fix it.
With a hedgehog.
Wait!
I should have given the hedgehog to Vicky.
I think I'm an idiot.
I didn't think about it until it happened.
No!
We'll get another hedgehog.
But
Nan, you can't be so serious.
I mean E env-wo-wo-wo-wo-wo-wo wo-wo, wo wowo-wo-wo-wo-wo
wo-wo-wo-wooo-wo.
E-wo-wo wo-wo-woo-wo wo-wowo.
Me...
Meow.
I love it.
That expression pretty much sums up who I am as a person.
It does.
I get frustrated when I can't express myself the way I want.
Torture.
Andragos!
Thank you so much for that 20 gift!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
What's going on here?
Oh, um...
That's it.
I'd like to play around with double-shadow, please.
We'll do it.
We'll do our best.
We got this one.
Here's your first mystery, double-shadow.
Okay, oh, he's walking as hedgehog!
That's the cakey jaw shit, and probably a lollipop.
The answer is...
Katie, Joel, our chef and lollipop.
Nice.
Next up, your second mystery double shadow.
What are these?
Fudge and...
Napa cabbage.
The answer is...
Fudge and Napa cabbage.
Oh, hello.
And without further ado, your last mystery double shadow.
What are these?
Please.
The correct answer is...
Why did he use another hedgehog?
Here he comes!
No!
It's a sugar glider!
He's coming for you, big boss.
Watching Phoebe closely.
Oh no!
I'll bring someone!
Oh, it's a lot!
Gah.
Come here.
Meet your neighbor.
Are you alright?
Nobody.
The stories right themselves.
I see.
This is gonna take a lot of elbow grease.
Oh, I just cleaned my elbows.
She's slapping me!
Torture!
This big boss is wearing perfume.
Don't worry about it.
Wait, do you guys see?
You guys see the fashion store has Vicky Cowboy and Ibu
Horse?
Why is it so perfect?
It's so good.
What is Haley Jalazman went?
My day has been so peaceful.
I haven't had to deal with him the whole time.
big boss right right who in Joe mama's house best represents
a charmer let's ask Joe is a represents a charmer okay I'll
grab Joe not that I care I think you do care if you're
asking who's Joe Gengar on three say which one of us in Joe
mama house comes to mind when you think of a charmer.
One, two, three.
Me.
There was much debate on the topic, and in the end, I'm glad
I heard Joe's opinion.
So awkward.
Yeah, the table is so empty.
I think the sentence, not that I care.
Um, while sleeping?
I'm such a fool.
No autographs!
Yarr, the sea calls!
I'm the only sane one.
It is so bad.
Wait.
I like that I'm such a fool.
Into the sea.
I'm such a fool.
I like it.
Into the sea.
There we go.
Gengar, really trying to get my intention back there.
I hear you, I hear you, I hear you.
I'm such a fool.
I love it.
That expression pretty much sums up who I am as a person.
I've got some time on my hands.
Do you want to play what's missing with me?
Yeah!
Wait, I haven't beat this one yet, have I?
Here's your first picture.
Oh, we have to pay attention.
So what's missing from here?
What's missing?
Uh...
Is that...
Oh, ration.
What's missing is...
Ration.
Next up, your second picture.
Alright.
So what's missing from here?
Free.
Coffee.
What's missing?
is coffee oh i want an oatmeal cookie that sounds so good
and finally the last picture so what's missing from here
three two fresh spring rolls the correct answer is
yes every time i see that little eye blue i'm like i know
it's you i know it's you i just finished an oatmeal cookie
and you did not offer it
It's gonna be a hedgehog.
Oh, I kind of want the Omamori though.
Oh damn, we can go sell this for big bucks.
Yeah, I know you guys, I can sniff you out so easily.
Something's for sale at the night market.
Oh, we got it!
We got something real special for you today.
In our mystery bag, it's...
Croquettes!
Oh, I love Croquettes.
It's...
Side gore ankle boots!
Variety show!
It's...
Princess dress.
Thanks a bunch.
What do Ibu smell like?
Like soap.
Probably.
I think.
I think they smell like soap.
I smell like soap.
I boo walking up to Frogbert.
We reached the way!
We could get the graveyard!
We can get the graveyard!
Wait, what's the new level up thing here?
New quirk.
The anger!
Congrats for your dream becoming reality.
Otsomito best of luck.
Thank you!
I love you!
See you!
So glad I tuned in on stream after a long while and
witnessed the confession live.
Congrats on getting the snake BF, Minto.
Thank you, Sapphire Eagle.
Thank you.
Appreciate it so much.
Thank you, everybody, for...
for cheering us on.
For, you know, never giving up on us.
It was tough.
It honestly was pulling teeth.
Wait, do we get a spooky photo?
Spooky photo?
Oh my god!
Wait, wait, wait, wait!
I want to be this one.
Oh my god.
This one can be Gengar.
We have so many ghosts on this island.
And obviously, this is you.
And this...
It can
be Vicky.
Headless.
And then this one...
Haley Jalazman.
Hot dog.
Hot dog indeed!
Cure me out.
Draw a little shadow of the hedgehog pet for Vicky.
That's a great idea!
We'll have Snake jumping out.
And then this one...
can be awesome.
And now...
Oh wait, no, I need Phoebe in there.
I was gonna say, hold on.
Phoebe can be in the trees.
No, Phoebe, we don't want Phoebe.
We don't want him ruining our photo.
This is perfect!
It's all my favorite people!
Cheese!
Wait, let me do it again.
Wait, shoot.
Oh, wait!
Oh, it's so good!
Oh, it looks so good!
It looks so good!
We've always been ghastly shaped.
That one's good, too.
Game boy.
Man, I also like the vivid.
Nice.
Oh, it looks so good.
Oh, I love that.
I love that the most just ever.
Oh my god!
I really...
Oh, I thought she was on.
I thought she was like super red in the face.
Love your Phoebe bee frog.
It looks hilarious, adorable, and entertaining.
Thank you!
Oh, uh, renovate.
There we go.
Nice.
It's time for the graveyard!
Oh my god!
I'm so happy!
She loves it.
Of course she loves it.
Alan Wake 3 looking good.
This is exactly the kind of room I wanted to live in.
Thank you.
Exactly!
When I needed help, Ocelot was there for me.
He's literally the absolute best.
She was.
is the best god i love ocelot god i love ocelot
let's go make a shadow for vicky as a pet let's go make one
he's gonna be a little treasure all right let me grab a
reference
Shadow.
A hedgehog.
Good, good, good.
Okay.
Is there a hedgehog stamp?
Oh, there might be, actually.
Oh!
There is!
Can I just change his color?
Look PNG?
No.
Wait, this is so cute though!
I was- hold on.
I'm gonna try making one first.
I want you guys to decide.
Okay.
I'm locked in.
actually
there we go and then any outlines can be done in black yeah
like his nose and stuff
I feel like this is more personable, you know?
Or more like, her.
Oh, wait.
It looks like a mustache.
Wait.
We'll do this.
There we go.
Oh, that was almost a great circle.
That was so close to being an awesome circle.
So close.
Just connect it.
There we go.
Like that, like so.
It's like a... it's like a Pomeranian shadow.
It's kind of the idea I'm going for.
What are you doing?
You don't see my vision!
You have some whimsy and some creativity.
Yeah, trust the process.
Trust the process.
Nah, I don't like that one.
Like so, add a little bit of twinkle in his eyes.
Shadow Fever's a popsicle like Sonic.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Kind of.
And then, back to this.
Like that?
Okay.
See?
You have to trust the process!
Ah,
there we go.
Hold on.
I'll get it perfect.
This you watch.
No.
Close enough.
No, no, it's his around-ish.
Okay, good enough.
There we go.
And then...
This.
Like so.
Yes.
Uh...
Buh-buh-buh-buh-buh-buh Buhbuh-buh Buhbuh-buh Buhbuhbuh
Nice.
Doesn't he kind of look like a, like a wet Pomeranian?
I mean, he's a hedgehog.
Don't get it, don't get it twisted, but...
But he's got like that sad wet Pomeranian.
wet dog energy.
It's kind of what I want for him.
I know that's not at all Vicky's vibe either, which makes it
funnier to me.
Soggy shadow.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
She's just soggy.
I think I made a second year too big.
Now I'm looking at it.
Oh no, I know.
There we go.
Okay, hold on.
Let me redo it.
Sorry.
Ah!
Oh!
Okay.
Yeah, pathetic little shadow.
You're just like, oh, you need to go party.
And he's like, he's like, oh, he's someone's a little grumpy
today.
You know?
Actually, wait, I might be going the wrong direction.
Something like...
Ugh!
What if it just says one ear?
Drawing the ears is so annoying.
Yeah!
His ears are back.
He's in defense mode.
I'm getting lost in the sauce.
There we go.
I was like, what am I looking for again?
He doesn't need to.
He uses bladder control.
Oh, I forgot to do...
Does that imply the existence of bladder emerald?
Whatever your little heart desires.
I think this is good.
No one can judge me.
Yeah, I think this is good.
What kind of pet is this?
Shadow.
Oh.
The.
Disappear.
Perfect.
Shadow the Hedgehog.
Shadow the Hedgepom?
Alright.
His trait is he's mysterious.
And his movement is...
What
do you think?
What with...
Gliding?
Sound is...
Oh, what does he say?
What does he say?
Oh, I know.
Voice type.
What?
Why is it just a voice?
Latinos?
There we go.
Latinas?
Latinos?
Let's go get him.
Welcome.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
All right.
Vicky!
Victoria the Hedge- I- okay, wait a second.
You guys see this?
Victoria the Hedgehog and Stephanie.
Snake are comparing poses.
He is literally interfering.
He thinks he's part of the team.
Are you serious?
They don't want you here.
They don't even notice that you're here.
He thinks he's part of the team.
Good evening.
Oh my gosh, I can't stand this guy.
Also, I need to give her an outfit.
You gave her a shadow, the hedgehog.
Why doesn't she like it?
She isn't sure if this is a good match for her!
No way!
Fake Vicky.
I need to give her this.
She'll come around.
So true.
I love it.
Yay!
Did you know Pee-Bee has the lucky big, big butt?
She was telling me all about it.
And I think we bonded in it.
Phoebe's got a lucky big, big butt, you say.
I mean.
Gosh, me too.
You talk about the most interesting things.
Oh, stop.
Chat.
You're way more entertaining to listen to.
When you get going, I left so hard.
I need to take my sides back together.
The way you're entirely wrong.
When you start talking, I start thinking your words should
be broadcast to the world.
Do you guys actually say good?
Really?
Do I talk about the most interesting things?
Why are we always like like this with each other?
No, I'm disagreeing for the sake of disagreeing.
The things you talk about should be animated and turn into
facial ink for us.
But...
Okay.
Just in case they want to turn this into a film, let's give
it a good ending and stop talking.
The good ending is us not talking anymore.
Understood.
Oh no, Snake!
He can't stop something.
He can't stop hiccuping!
I'll bring Osalot.
I'll bring Osalot!
He's listening to Forever Meow.
He's perfect.
Something unique.
No, no, come here!
Come here!
To Snake!
Actually, how's anyone?
None of the means have gotten sick, huh?
Hick, hiccups.
They won't stop.
Hick.
Ha ha.
There's the source of the problem.
Aipu is a Minto's never won fan in every universe.
You might need to use a little moru.
Eee!
Thank you.
Anyone would have helped.
Okay.
Nothing happened.
Okay, we're safe.
We're safe.
Okay.
Maybe.
What if Ocelot steals it from me?
I mean, it's the wrong snake, but it would be crazy to see.
Do you want it to happen?
I mean...
I've had... I was able to...
I was able to be with him even for a second, so...
I think it's alright.
Oh, Gengar is bored.
Hey, but what's wrong?
Not the sugar glider.
You're looking cheaper, big boss.
As the other half of the bones down, I want to express my
appreciation to you.
Great idea.
What should I say?
Oh.
Uh, what would Frogbird want to hear?
Oh, I know, I know.
I know, I know.
You?
I got you a green card.
Let's do this.
That's what Frogbert's always been after.
A green card.
Because he's green.
Rupert, I have something I want to say to you.
What's going on?
This is out of the blue.
I got you a green card.
Aibu, you're the only one who would ever say something like
that to me.
Thank you.
Oh, Aibu!
Aibu!
Mary for four days.
It may just burst.
Super in- Okay, but Aibu sees you as soulmate, so come on,
Frogbird.
What the hell?
Frogbird, or Aibu sees you so much more.
why is he following on top of him like that oh what's wrong
oh they're talking about talking about urban sucking life
energy legends we'll leave them to that frogbird will come
around I hope so wait this is maybe the greatest this is may
be the greatest day of my life of me mental life my
afterlife he trackles the shaman with it yeah and that's a
twin doodle at sepal pack ranching hern good my lapandi
basic tomorrow bronco i'm a bumble tornado saw hanji
clasping yesterday i can't look at i can't look at this i
can't look at that i can't i can't even know that that's
happening and that's existing I can't, I can't, I can't, I
can't,
I...
No way.
No way!
Who is that?
Quetzalcoatless.
Huh.
I suddenly feel all mixed up.
Gengar is so after everybody.
I like Snack, but I also have feelings for Quetzalcoatless.
Snack is taken!
Who do you think I really like?
Gengar contender for Freakiest on the Island.
This guy is after everybody.
Who should I say?
Will we finally find the one this time?
Give up on Snake and go for Ketzel-Kuatlas.
Take Snake away from Minto.
If it's going to be anybody, it will be us a lot.
I know, but kind of the drama.
This feels like the dogen has already been written about.
Don't you guys want Gengar to be happy?
I think it's got to be, it's got to be Ketzel-Kuatlas.
My love for Snop is dying down.
I think I like Quetzalcoatlus.
Like boo.
Does this guy even know he exists?
Great friends.
Oh!
Crushing?
Likes a lot!
You just met the guy.
I mean, I couldn't get over that beak either.
He's just staring at him.
position got taken you've been moved to the side window oh
is that like confetti and stuff in the back that's crazy oh
i got chills i can't believe it's happening in there
What are Phoebe's doing?
Sitting by the tree.
How's she feeling?
Are you hungry?
Wait, did I feed Phoebe?
Ahati.
Ahati!
I will give you a sausage.
It might be your favorite ever.
It's gonna be your favorite.
Nope.
She liked it.
It's so hard to find a favorite food.
When I talk to Mickey and I think things like, we both got
super angry I know.
Yeah, we don't have cheese.
Wait, we can make cheese puffs?
We can make some.
What is happening here?
The music is, like, making me sick.
Oh,
so I...
Um...
Want to play coin spin?
Yeah.
Wait, what's coin spin?
Guess which side the coin will it... Oh, when it stops
spinning.
Oh, okay.
What do you think it'll be?
Tails, Tails, Tails!
Ew, I don't want to see it anymore!
Tails, huh?
Well, let's see if you like it.
Tails, Tails, Tails!
Oh, too bad.
It's heads.
Boop, boop, boop, boop.
Hey, you can't...
What am I getting?
What's my toilet paper?
The way he's like smirking at me when he gives that to me.
Ah, some me's are planning on gathering here.
What are they gonna do?
Wait!
I need to give Ocelot his cowboy outfit!
Oh, whoops.
Um...
I need to give him... I mean, he...
He's gonna have a hat on.
We'll give him a hat on.
a better hat later once we get the beret.
Hey, relaxer!
Nice.
We need an...
We do not need an emote.
Oh my god, the hedgehog!
They're observing this hedgehog together since it's It's too
terrifying to approach the look.
Why are they always so terrified of their pets?
Have you noticed that?
They're always like, they're always freaked out.
I see Minto.
Look, she's on cloud.
She's on cloud nine right now.
She's like the happiest she's ever been ever.
She could honestly...
She could honestly like...
I was gonna say she could go to heaven.
Oh, I thought I couldn't even read the about part.
They're trading secrets.
I thought it said they're trading secrets with your mom.
They're trading secrets with your mom.
Hold on, let's see if we can get a better outfit for you.
for a...
Wait.
What do you want, Fabian?
Let's play moving cups together.
Moving cups?
We haven't played that one before.
Oh.
I promise there are no tricks or secrets to do.
Okay.
Keep your eyes on the top with the coin.
Here we go.
Okay.
Where is the coin hiding?
Oh.
In the middle?
She's gaslighting me!
It's definitely the middle?
Oh wait, I lost it at the very last second!
I lost it completely.
Wait, it's not left anymore, right?
Middle?
Middle now?
Yes.
If I say right hand...
Oh, that's surprising.
I totally thought you'd stay left.
Where is the coin hiding?
Oh my gosh!
You guys are cracked!
I thought it was the left.
That's the one I was gonna pick.
Oh, but then she did the last switch up on me.
Congratulations.
You won.
Yippee!
Let's go big or go home.
Oh, we got...
Oh, I could have gotten a cap.
We got a chip.
video game soundtrack.
What I was gonna do is go look for better clothes for
Ocelon.
I think...
Let's see what hats we have.
I'm sure we can get a red beret.
You know?
We'll have anything.
Wait.
Anything in the daily specials?
No.
A tiara is just as good.
We could give him the beanie.
But it's not the right.
It's not right.
Cowboy.
He's already wearing that, you guys.
I already gave him the cowboy outfit.
What's going on here?
The shadow of the hedgehog smiled at them so sweet.
they'll never be the same and it's impossible it's
impossible he'll never do that i boo yearns for the horse
costume her go oh snake's face looks exactly like oh his
face is exactly like shadows so is vicky's oh dang it i
missed it but hold on we'll get it there it is yeah nice
Oh, oops.
Wrong place.
Kind of spooky.
Why is there like an ambiance?
Hi, Blue is sleeping.
Oh, it's this one where they count sheep.
White sheep.
To sheep.
Eww.
Hmm.
Another one?
I feel like I've been getting a lot of dupes of stuff.
Of like dreams and...
Hmm.
You know?
Oh, let's give up.
Okay.
Aibu is going to love a ration.
He's gonna love...
This...
Oh my goodness, he was starving!
He was ravenous!
Okay.
I just had the deepest conversation with Rupert.
About what?
And when I said I got to the ring part, it worked out.
No kidding.
Who hasn't eaten?
Maybe Ketzel Kauatlas hasn't eaten.
Good evening.
Okay, he's kind of hungry.
Like, he can eat more.
Do you want the kimchi?
No.
That Ibu's when we go a day without me.
Okay, you liked it.
It's so difficult.
I will find it.
You never will if you don't get out of your comfort zone
every so often.
You're right, but it makes me uncomfortable.
I think she's talking to herself.
Alright.
Who hasn't eaten?
Who is this?
Ocelot, I'm pretty sure I gave him food.
The Gengar eat!
They're blaming...
Oh, they're blaming...
They're claiming the Shadow the Hedgehog is a beacon of hope
in a cruel and uncary universe.
Oh, Minto is streaming!
Minto streaming?
Save us Shadow the Hedgehog.
They're talking about how they can't hide their agitation
when reading these isek guide to the sexy timeline.
I'm just gonna... Okay, Frog Bird, have you eaten?
Greetings Canada.
A little bit.
I can't stop laughing.
I'm boo-boos.
I got you a green card.
Story is too much.
I'm happy for you.
I'm so happy for you.
I'm gonna give you some croquettes.
Yum.
Agitation.
Why are they angry?
Oh, we even better...
Better than pizza!
Wow.
Ending a sentence, maybe we can do...
Boingo.
I love croquettes, though, it's true.
Bazinga!
Thank you.
Now I feel more like myself.
Boingo.
Oh,
he's back to the conversation?
They feel like...
They feel that one can't discuss these asikki to the sexy
timeline without mentioning the line.
Everyone was in disbelief.
Greetings, Canada!
Wait, what's wrong, Snake?
He's washing the thoughts away.
Unreal Citizen, thank you so much for the super chat!
What's wrong?
I'm in a bit of a funk.
Oh, no, a snake hasn't been fed.
You need a Salisbury steak.
You'll love it.
Yum.
Boingo.
Disbelief of what?
Not more than a butter cookie, though.
I feel like a heavy weight has been lifted from my
shoulders.
Why was it sad, though?
Hrnka, Minky and I are dating now.
I'm going to do everything I can to make her happy.
I'm so glad I took the leave.
Oh, thank you, Snake.
This is too sweet.
Look at them walking in the sunset.
Oh, it's so beautiful.
Oh.
It's so cute!
Where's she going?
Wait, I don't think Vicky's eaten either.
Something on your mind.
No, she hasn't.
Oh, whoops.
I'm running out of food here, but...
Smores are her favorite thing ever.
Yum.
Okay,
well, close.
Over roast beef.
I know, smores aren't really dang good.
I'm starting to get hungry too.
I have another stream?
Well, I won't be streaming my POV.
Actually today Steiner was just like, Minto, were you
confused?
On your schedule you put you were doing schedule one with
Phoebe, but it's actually Lymu.
It's because when Pia first asked me about the collab, she
said that she asked Henya and Phoebe.
So I was like, oh okay, I'm playing with Henya and Phoebe.
And then I never realized that instead Lymu got added to the
group.
I'm not crazy!
I'm not crazy.
Let's give her some macho.
She's gonna love it.
You think
snake calls Minto is butter cookie?
We can make him do that.
It's a little disgusting, but we could do it, I guess.
Miki, wiki, wiki, wiki, wiki.
We need to have her say that.
Once she levels up, we'll get her to say Vicky Punch.
Okay, wait, hold on.
More food!
You're gonna love this macaron.
Yum.
True.
Ah, not more than the s'mores though.
Wait, can I give her just one more thing?
A peach?
Wait, what if she loves it?
was the peach wouldn't wait it actually might be scripted if
if peach is her favorite thing oh dang it i was hoping it
was an hour later mr confession congrats mickey who
confessed to whom jessica thank you a snake confessed to
minke yes it happened it happened it's me victoria the
hedgehog
Vicky Punch!
Vicky Punch.
Punch.
I gave her an expression.
Vicky Punch.
I love it.
That expression pretty much sums up who I am as a person.
Thumbs up.
Wow, she is like ultra-friendly.
Good friends, good friends, good friends.
Very nice.
Oh, what's going on here?
What's going on?
I want to sneak in on their date.
I want to watch.
Oh, yeah.
My darling Minky.
What's the plan for tomorrow's date?
Plisskin, my dear.
I want to do some with your mom.
So how about we go to the ocean?
You read my mind.
I've dreamed of with your mom by the ocean with you for the
longest time.
Our love will last a lifetime.
We'll be together forever.
Let's begin.
No!
Hey, Minky, my truest flow.
I really gotta ask you something.
Which is cooler?
Me or a forever meow?
No, let's begin.
My silly dear.
Me or a forever meow?
Minky, what have you created?
Then you're a million times cooler than a forever meow.
Minky Meow We'll last a lifetime We'll be together forever
Pliskin
My darling Pliskin What is it exactly that you love about
me?
Pliskin What is it about?
I swear you're so extra, Minky What?
I want to be that extra!
I got me mama and snake You look too cool The way you were
sucking life energy I knew I had to be with you So it really
worked The whole reason I was sucking life energy was to try
and get a reaction from you Our love will last a lifetime.
We'll be together forever, Minky.
Get me out of here.
Big, big, butt.
What narwhal plums do you need to go great?
Runga, beautiful bosom.
Get me out of here.
Oh.
Vicky!
She fell!
Oh wait, no, I didn't mean to die.
I have to help her.
Dang it.
By her butt.
I'll grab her by the butt.
Oh, the leg.
And that works too.
How is that wholesome conversation so freaky?
With your mom by the beaches, Diapolical.
I want to do some with your mom by the beach.
I can't!
Believe me, no!
I think I could take a nice nap here.
No!
Oh.
That's a koala.
What if he draws on your face?
I should think about getting up.
Oh no!
He buried you inside him.
Who did this?
Oh.
Wish I knew why.
You're exhausted?
Is that what he just said?
I'm exhausted.
Wish I knew why.
Why is Vicky not getting along with him?
Uh-oh.
That's awkward.
Oh, gosh.
My kamioshi is so calm and normal.
Vicky be sucking less things.
Life energy.
I mean, it's a normal ghost thing.
It just sounds really weird to you humans.
But for ghosts, it sounds normal.
I- I'm always sucking your life energy!
That's how I'm able to stay in the form that you see me as!
But!
You guys just don't understand!
You guys just don't get it!
Oh, I want the toy sword.
That's fun.
You guys just don't understand me.
Once you die, maybe.
I got a new picture.
Oh, that's so fun.
Wait, what's the group one then?
I love the haunted forest.
It's my favorite ever.
Oh, that's good.
The way we need to make Raiden right now!
We need to make him.
Ah, we understand you, with your mom.
We get you much better now, please.
Hey, what's happening here?
Oh.
Forever meow!
This is so- who's taking pictures?
Oh.
What's he taking pictures of?
Hmm.
Okay, let's make Raiden real quick.
Sorry, I'm suddenly making everybody Metal Gear.
All right, Metal Gear Solid 2 Raiden.
Metal Gear Solid 2 Raiden.
I
was just told that, finally, very soon, for the Densetsu
concert will finally be able to be announced!
Yippee!
Ah, my guest soon, soon, soon.
They're waiting on one last thing, but it should happen very
soon.
Just depends on when they get that last thing.
Mmm, mmm, mmm, mmm.
Yay, I was just told.
Yippee!
Okay, ride in.
Ride in.
Turn off the game console.
right now okay ride in is also okay ride in space is
actually this all right and my man is a blonde blonde take
this guy to the salon yeah
saucy jack time before he gets sauced before he's sauced
let's see the bangs are kind of like
almost like yes and no maybe we can find something better
let's see what it looks like if we change the back oh that's
not bad wait that's not bad at all wait that's actually
pretty nice I do have an image reference hold on
funny because like he looks different from his nendroid the
nendroid this suits the nendroid image so much more actually
what if we go off the nendroid and make him like super bc
ikiman let's try like that sorry i don't i just picked this
from a website i have no idea where it's from oh it's from
ebay we're
going with this except for his face because his face is
extremely like actually, I don't know, hold on, let me get
another image hold on let's go off of this one but also keep
the nendroid in mind keep the nendroid in mind listen
make him eat gum powder I can make him eat gum powder!
Oh my gosh!
Wait!
I'm gonna make him eat so much gum powder oh my gosh oh my
gosh it's good it's good i can make every gun powder
maybe like that and his eyes okay
but we went with these for us a lot i don't know if i want
to go with them for for uh for riden too looking so close to
each other.
His eyebrows are super thin, are they?
I... they are very thin.
Good catch.
Maybe like, uh...
We could always thin...
We could always thin them out.
Oh, that's better, that's better.
What if he loves gunpowder?
Then it's meant to be!
What kind of taste does gunpowder have?
What does it have?
Wait, I forgot to do the nose.
Let's give him, like, the long, pointy nose.
Oh, my gosh, he looks like a stereotypical yaoi guy.
He looks like a yaoi guy.
Gunpowder tastes like balsamic vinegar.
No way.
That sounds delicious.
I don't want these eyes, but they suit him so well.
And the only reason is because they look so similar to
Ocelots, you know?
But they're like literally him.
They are so him.
These ones too, actually.
Wait a second.
Wait, unless I can...
I
don't know.
I feel like the other one worked better.
Which, actually...
Hmm.
Which do you guys like better?
one two there's also this one though
two seems more correct I know that's what I'm saying
this one looks better
more forehead
the ones above the initial one seems similar to Oh, this
one?
It's not bad?
It's hard to say.
The eyeliner.
He does have like crazy...
Look at this guy.
I mean, you guys.
Scott.
Look.
Okay.
When I say that Ryden has crazy eyelashes, you can see them
crazy here.
See?
Like he has to have the lower lashes.
He's got crazy eyelashes.
I know such dreamy eyes.
They're nice and sharp though.
He is such a pretty boy.
Let's see.
You can go back to his...
You can go back to his me.
Maybe we can do him smiling.
Just a little guy.
I say this is pretty good, though.
Needs thicker lips?
I think so.
Oh,
no!
No, not reset!
Oh, dang it.
Let me change the...
To be, like, a...
A skin color-ish, you know.
It looks too ridiculous.
Why can't the lips, like, go all the way across?
He could be Shigo.
Kimpossible.
This one could work.
It's kind of creepy smile.
It's a little wide.
This one could work.
Maybe.
Call me, beat me, if you want to reach me.
Not bad.
Not bad at all.
These seem like a little too wide-eyed now.
Now that I'm like looking at them, you know?
I feel like this.
Yeah, he is a squinty boy.
Yeah, I feel like this works.
Yeah.
This is so riding.
Some of the narrower eyes.
I was looking at them.
I feel like they're so dramatically narrow, though.
Oh.
Hold on.
But he's like got like the type of eyes.
They're like flat on the top and more round on the bottom.
Like they're the opposite of this.
Like they're like this.
But not so, you know.
Narrow with angst.
That's just sleep deprived.
No, that's the egg you saw.
That's like the popular thing.
That's like in...
That's your...
Not your waterline.
The Namida Bukuro.
The, that's the, that's the, it's, it's very common.
It's popular, like, Asian aesthetic.
That looks freaky.
I think, I think this is a good one.
I think it really represents him well.
As a pretty boy.
It's so popular in China.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Ride in Namida Bokuro.
I love Namida Bokuro.
I think they're so cute.
I wish I could get some hair around like this side.
Hold on.
Let me see if there's a hairstyle that like brings some more
hair, some hair down the sides, you know.
Oh, oh, it's not totally accurate, but oh, bad boy ride in.
I feel like this is the closest We've Like something like
that almost, you know But with bangs
Nah He's so yaoi I mean Like his bangs need to be more
sweepy
We'll go with this though I think it works Yeah, I think it
looks way more like him then this this looks like oh my gosh
this looks like Felix from miraculous ladybug I hope nobody
in the chat understands that reference okay his personality
is gunpowder baby no you're right skinny skinny skinny I've
heard of the show but never watched it that's fine that's
probably okay honestly Raiden my name is Raiden my name is
Raiden how okay let's see ride ride it ride ride and rock oh
that's good nesting okay
Raiden oh good good good My name is Ryden.
My name is Ryden.
Let's see.
Oh, perfect!
Yippee!
Ryden!
I think my island has so many men.
I think...
My island is just all guys.
Oh.
Wait, oh gosh We'll do April 30th as his birthday Because he
doesn't have one
April 30th And we'll make him a ripe 21 Yeah, we are Oh My
name is Raiden It's nice to meet My name is Raiden My name
is Raiden My name is Raiden My name is Raiden.
My name is Raiden.
It's not my name is my name is Raiden.
It's nice to meet you.
Today is April 28th, 2026.
You may have Fulton in a few.
So how does this voice sound?
Jason, happy birthday!
It's my birthday in Raiden.
It's one of my favorite characters in Metal Gear.
I couldn't ask her for B-heroes.
Yay!
Happy birthday!
My name is Raiden.
Happy happy birthday!
It's nice to meet you.
Today is April 28th, 2026.
So, how does this voice sound?
My name is Raiden.
It's nice to meet you.
He's questioning everything because of the Patriots.
Today is April 28th, 2026.
Did you just say nerd?
So, how does this voice sound?
Perfect.
Did you just say nerd?
No.
All right.
Um, Ryden is a little slow because of his brain.
His speech is more polite than honest because you have to
press the buttons to know what he's really thinking.
His energy is varied.
He's quite serious about stuff.
And overall, he's actually more normal than not.
dating preferences everybody's at risk
do not bring up king kong around this guy oh good we're
getting like new personalities a perfectionist aloof logical
tenacious cautious speaks matter of factly imaginative and
inspired happiness happiest when creating something finds
beauty in everyone and everything
chill honestly where should we build Ryden's house it's hard
to characterize Ryden I fear he's got like such a you know
he's just himself oh he's on the island uh oh can one of his
phrases be did you say nerd yes it will nice to meet you I'm
Ryden I'm I'm a reserved perfectionist.
I'm serious, particular, and pretty clever.
He looks so yowie!
Oh my god!
I'm looking forward to living here.
He looks so!
Wow.
He's born...
Yeah, I saw that he was born in 83.
I guess we could have made him older, but it's okay.
Let's give him something to eat.
for you.
Welcome to the island.
He likes it so much!
Don't worry, everybody.
Gunpowder is on the menu.
I guess I'm kind of a people pleaser.
How's I want to give him new clothes?
Do we have anything?
Oh.
Perfect.
We should make him a little Metal Gear Ray as a pet.
That'd be so cute.
What if we made my island look like the big shell?
What if like all the houses were like different, like the
little...
What if everything was like, you know...
Wait, what do you mean less than an hour until the collab?
The collab starts at 10 p.m.
my time.
The collab is in four hours for me.
Ah, I can't get wet t-shirt contest off my mind.
I love the sea.
Yeah.
Oh, Hennia's just starting stream early, so people are
probably confused.
Oh, okay.
I'm not one guide, I was telling the fact.
I want to try wet t-shirt contest.
Ah.
You're yelling at Vicky's house!
Wait, I have to build him a thing so that he can, uh...
Oh, there's a lot going on.
Okay, hold on.
Hold on!
We gotta build a staircase for him so we can...
So we can leave.
Wait, how do I... Where is it?
Staircase.
We need a staircase for him.
Wait, is there not staircases?
Uh-oh, wait.
Oh, there it is.
There it is.
Thank you very much.
Thank you!
Alright, uh...
Island builder?
Build...
Staircase.
Very nice.
Sure!
Yeah, we'll also build him a little pathway to his house and
everything.
Um...
Even though he lives there, in the sand.
Wow, he's got like a beachfront property.
That's kind of crazy.
Uh.
Oh, this is dirt path.
Wait.
Undo.
Let's do, uh...
Is there sand?
Oh, sandy beach.
Oh, wait.
That just makes it a sandy beach.
We'll do...
Hmm.
Oh, I can't do it right there.
That's kind of weird.
Wait, oh, I can't do it there either.
Oh, okay, that looks terrible.
Okay, hold on.
Oh, because it's like, oh, uh, we need the pathway.
The dirt pathway.
Oh, you can't.
Ah.
Uh.
He knows how to get home.
Probably.
He knows how to get home, most likely.
We can always, I'll move him.
I love to see.
Why are you shouting it over there?
Ah, the sea.
Made outfit?
Okay, we got a lot going on.
Let's check out Gengar first.
Dropping in.
He's daydreaming of Ketzel Gwattless.
He is so real for that.
Made out for it?
Hey, do that thing again.
Wait, are they eating ration?
Oh.
Oh, I want to be sweethearts like boo.
Like boo.
He wants to be sweethearts.
Are you guys working together?
Oh, they are.
Up for a game of group, no repeat.
Oh, yeah.
Let's play.
Naika, thank you.
He's staring at a wall screaming about how he loves the
scene.
Not directionally challenged at all.
No repeats.
Food.
Okay.
Smoor.
Beef jerky.
Fish cakes.
Spinach.
Korean chili pepper.
pepper chicken tikka masala kimchi scrambled eggs loco moco
pano chocolate gratin gratin nut chill what is that i never
had those orange what's new spice chrysalis sprouts pickles
Oh, it's getting tense.
It's getting tense.
Candy apple.
Bloco-mo-loco?
I don't know if somebody...
Ah!
Yeah!
Whew.
That was tough.
I don't remember if someone said scrambled eggs or not.
So I didn't pick it up.
What a bit.
A bamboo box is inside a bamboo box.
Come on,
Ketzelko Atlas.
Oh.
I want to be friends with Phoebe.
Yes, great thinking.
What should we talk about?
You should talk about, let's see, with Phoebe.
With Phoebe.
Cheese balls!
That's so good!
Talk about a cheese ball.
A cheese balls.
Why can't you do plural thing in this game?
It's so annoying.
I kind of hate that.
What's my biggest complaint?
Besides taking out the, uh, the, uh, what's it called?
The concert hall?
A bucket of cheese balls!
That's better.
Bucket O cheese balls, yeah.
Will it fit?
Oh, chase.
Chase is balls.
I thought you could.
It's either A or Ann.
You can't change it.
It's kind of annoying.
What if, though?
What if not a bucket?
Not ballsy.
But what if a...
Hold on, we have room, right?
metric ton.
A metric ton of cheeseballs.
Metric ton of cheeseballs.
Got it.
I'll go talk to her about a metric ton of cheeseballs.
Nice.
That's a lot of cheeseballs.
Good evening.
Phoebe.
Do you feel like talking about a metric ton of cheese balls
sure but let me ask you this someone offers you a large
metric ton of cheese balls or a small metric oh no wait
which one are you going with wait this is the same as a ton
of feathers wait or wait one feather worth that's weighs a
ton versus one wait
That's too bad.
I'm a big fan of a big metric ton of cheese balls myself.
Uh-oh.
I guess she doesn't want to hang with someone who likes a
small metric ton of cheese balls.
No!
Not the small... They're the same!
They're not a metric ton of cheese balls!
They're the same!
We just couldn't get on the same thing.
Yeah, well, a kilogram of steel or a kilogram of feathers.
I'm going to make a friend.
No!
They're the same!
Let's give him a new outfit.
He'll feel better, maybe.
It's just kind of messed up.
But Steel is heavier than Cheeseballs.
He loves it!
My Terra Dinosaur!
Has been lifted from my shoulders.
Look, Minto, what's wrong?
Does she want...
Does she want to be friends with Ryden?
Moe-moe-boo.
I want to try living with Genki.
What?
Wait, why?
Wait, but what about you and...
What?
I'm confused.
But, what about Snake?
Yeah, wait, Gengar lives with...
Yeah, Haley, Joe Osmond, no?
Aren't they in Joe Mama's house?
You're not a Joe.
Maybe she'll live with Snake once they get married.
And...
Do you think Gengar is trying to, like...
But no, Gengar likes Ketzel Kuala Atlas now.
Let's do it.
If I lived with Gengi, we'd be spending a lot of time
together.
It's Gingy and I live together.
Uh-oh, wait, but they already talked about sucking life
energy.
As a ghost, spend your days haunting.
Haunting.
And...
Like, haunting and stuff.
Haunting.
haunting and stuff I think you're right I'll go talk to him
I'm so I just it's the drama you guys we got to do for the
drama hey hey can we chat for a moment she's totally
ignoring her what is it seems important well if the two of
us live together what's something you think we enjoy doing
every day
Let's say it together.
On three.
One, two, three.
Hunting and stuff.
I knew it.
A perfect match.
You guys, we went to Kyoto together.
We're besties.
Ghosts strong.
Also, I just want to see the houses get bigger, you know,
and like more people living in like the bigger houses and
stuff.
I think that's kind of fun.
This is gonna be a blast.
Yeah, Snake needs to move in too.
Oh.
In a new...
Wait, we can kick him out?
We can kick out Agent...
We can kick out Joe!
Joe!
In a whole new house.
I'll get my hard hat.
Should we bring along anyone I've been living with?
What the hell?
I forgot that you live there.
You look so funny.
We'll live over here and be happier and healthier.
Oh, we're trapped.
Actually, we gotta move some stuff around.
It's fine.
I'm sure we'll have a great time living in this house
together.
Say, do you have any ideas for what to call our household?
If you have a good name for us, I'd love to hear it.
I've got the perfect one.
The...
The Boo House.
Nice.
The Boo Crew!
That is a house.
The Boo House!
We shall be henceforth known as the Boo House.
Thanks for the excellent idea.
I hope you'll keep checking in on us, the members of the Boo
House.
Yeah!
Whoa.
Did you really like that?
Okay, hold on.
Let's build real quick before we, uh, before we get...
Alright.
You need to go, like, somewhere else so that we can...
I'll just put him right here for now.
and we'll move this here and we'll move him by Haley Joel
Osman or rather Haley Joel Osman by Raiden very
nice yes the
blue house is house
it's fine don't worry about it why
are they doing that why is he doing that when they're
strangers.
That's weird.
That's really weird.
That's pretty bizarre.
Wow.
I think, yeah, he's trying to kill him.
What a weird version of Akuroku.
Are you cooking here?
Ark, come on.
It's not Akuroku.
There's no way.
Of all the days to step on a forever meow, it had to be
today.
Look how different they are in every way.
Wait, is...
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, wait.
Is he stalking him or not?
What's he...
Oh, he's into this now.
What is it?
What is that?
What is that, Ryzen?
Yeah, they have matching outfits.
I need these two to meet right now.
Um...
Hello.
It's nice to meet you.
My name is Raiden.
Hearn go.
Hello there, Raiden.
I'm known as Snake.
All right.
Raiden is humbly talking about himself in the hope of making
a new friend.
He says, do you like gunpowder?
My skin got a soupy.
Yeah.
Mind if we stop talking about this, Raiden.
It's about himself!
Hey.
Well.
You okay, buddy?
You need something?
I talked to Snake, but it didn't go well.
I'm kind of disappointed.
Let's give him, let's give him...
Oh.
What do you want?
You want a...
Uh...
You want...
A Hawaiian key chain?
Okay.
Oh, it's just not his day.
Oh, Ryden.
Yeah, some tissues.
I want the tissues to stop crying.
Some tissues to stop your tears.
There you go.
Ryden, I'll leave you alone.
I'll let you just...
Maybe?
No.
Oh, Raiden!
Raiden, I'm sorry!
Oh, he just moved here and he's having such a hard time.
What are you doing over here?
Oh, nice.
This is MGS4, Raiden.
Oh, it's painful.
Make friends with Halo Joao.
Um, hello.
It's nice to meet you.
Not that I care.
My name is Haley Joel Osment.
You're Haley Joel Osment?
I'm riding.
Surely this will work.
This is a match made in heaven.
A funny rumor involving an eye boom.
What are you saying?
What does that mean?
You're so funny?
What?
The slander seems like-minded.
That's a terrible compliment.
See, he's not sad anymore.
All is well, all is fine.
You do it.
positive thoughts.
Are you okay?
What's wrong with him?
You can do it if you try.
He's doing positive affirmations?
Just in the grass?
What did he say about us?
I told you, are you guys going to continue to be on Haley
Joel Osmond's side when this is what he's saying about you?
Huh?
Are you going to continue being on his side?
He's spreading lies and slander.
We gotta get rid of him.
Oh my god, stop being annoying.
The bone zone.
Wait, why is Snake there?
Actually, why is Snake there?
Oh, he thinks they're best friends.
Wait, but Frogbert doesn't think the same at all.
Frogbert doesn't like him anymore.
They're discussing the toilet paper.
Uh oh.
There's like drama.
There's like subtle drama going on.
You can make today a good day.
Oh, there's positive affirmations.
Um.
Is he feeling better now?
The cracks are forming.
Yeah, everybody hung out just because it was like, oh,
there's only like two people to hang out with.
We have to, you know.
We have to.
We have to be friends.
We have to get along because there's no one else.
But now that there's other people.
Hold on.
I'm going to go find an outfit for Ryzen.
We're going to go get him a good outfit.
I don't like what he's wearing.
Ah.
Something with a corset.
Something nice and tight.
Where's the sombrero?
I don't have one yet.
Let's go back to the daily special.
See if there's anything here.
I need more clothes.
Sheared, layered, top?
The scarf would look cute.
Oh yeah, I want to put him in something and then he would,
like, look good in, you know?
Maybe?
Oh my gosh.
It's a school AU.
Right in school AU.
Alright, come here.
Oh, wait.
I also need to get him his room.
Welcome.
Thank you, Bear.
Please come again.
Metal Gear AU, just like my doujins.
Yeah, I can't remember if it was official or not, but there
was like a Tokimeki crossover Metal Gear image.
And I think about that a lot, how like a Metal Gear Tokimeki
game would just be so good.
I already had one.
This is exactly the kind of room I wanted to live in.
Thank you.
It just really...
It's just so poetic.
All right, here's your A.
We'll give him a sneaking suit.
Maybe I'll draw one once I can.
Oh, my gosh.
You don't like anything, you picky.
This is just like my simulations.
All right, we have one last wishing fountain.
And I spoiled optimal male living space.
Level 22!
What else we got?
A basket torch.
What?
I want the bouncy playground run!
This one really blurs the line between still unpacking and I
live among the boxes.
We'll give this one to Snake.
He really is MGS2 riding.
He really is!
He's picky and annoying and sad.
No way.
We got another travel.
ticket we interrupt to bring you some breaking news an
exciting new travel destination is now available a Latin
America tour is now available at the wishing fountain I'll
give it to Vicky she'll take she'll take Sonic and one
resident is saying I hope my roommate is gifted a trip soon
I could really use the alone time it looks like a wig all
right thanks for watching I'm riding
Western Euro I have Victoria the Hedgehog
Take Shadow Take him home Oh Are you really giving me a
Latin America tour?
Thank you so much Time to pack my bags In it?
In it?
this bitch has been on every fucking tour I'm so sick of
seeing his face oh my god please bring somebody else he
cannot be this beloved by everybody it's a lie whatever
they're looking at must be pretty interesting say cheese Oh,
I like that one.
That's funny.
Nice to meet you.
What should eat you?
Say cheese.
Where's your buddy?
I'm not even saving these.
They make me angry.
Actually, I like the one where they're staring.
King Or is everyone's best friend in wonder?
He knows hypnosis.
Oh, that's the hypnosis.
What is that?
What?
What did I just receive?
Does Easter Island really count as Latin America?
I was wondering that.
I feel like maybe I don't know where Easter Island is.
Welcome.
You can have it.
You can have...
Wait!
If only there were oranges, it would be perfect!
Thank you, Vic.
Please come again.
been fighting off a cold the past couple days no i please
request a feel better weave miss insanity feel better we
please feel better please feel better please feel better not
the colds board on the street is that quetzalcoatless has
really upped his game lately kind of game are we talking
about checkers because i crushed him the last time we played
snake why do you always have to make this about checkers we
know you're good at and vicky yeah let's stay focused on
quetzalcoatless and how bad he is at checkers no that's so
mean i've been so low energy lately i wonder if it's because
my diet consists of only not caviar is packed with energy i
think i'm not a registered dietitian maybe i should try
eating that way i know a place that specializes in caviar in
fact the menu is just one line caviar scrawled in crayon
maybe it's not a real restaurant scary what do we get from
this one i wonder
Oh, it was just a dream.
I wonder how much they buy.
A restaurant menu.
Mmm.
One thing I love about Caesarea is they have, um...
Oh, I'm hearing this.
The pond show up.
Oh, my goodness.
I also remember we have the diamond.
Nice seeing you here.
Thank you.
Nice stuff you got.
Um...
Come back again.
Asides Area, they have a...
Like a...
What's the difference between these two pictures thing that
they switch out periodically?
They're talking over each other!
It's a... It's a Fokky-me thing?
Okay, there was one last thing I was gonna do... Oh, Snake.
Where are you?
Oh, here you are.
What are you doing?
waiting huh kept you waiting huh yeah yeah entire room
goodbye to goodbye to your garage and hello to your boxes
huh it was a hit
Wait, there is an orange right there!
It looks right now!
Thank you!
Nice!
Yippee!
Well, guys, oh my gosh, I almost played for four hours of
this game.
Holy cow.
It's so easy to get swept up in it, though.
Um, but yeah, thanks for more Tomodachi life!
Oh, we finally have Asawat!
Snake finally confessed.
to Minto.
We got a ride.
They weren't wrong when it's called Living the Dream, huh?
I think I'm living the dream.
Torgon, thank you!
Thanks for the stream, Minto.
It's nice that Snake and Minto finally got together.
He really kept us waiting, huh?
Glad it all worked out, by the way.
Oh, by the way, do you know what day it is today?
Here's a hint.
It's not a...
Oh my gosh.
Wait, I just realized Charlie at this in two days.
Holy cow!
Show our princess, thank you!
Minky, Minky, Minky, Minky, Minky, Minky, Minky, Minky,
Minky, Minky, Minky, Minky, Minky, Minky, Minky, Minky!
Today's the take your cover.
I can't say goodbye.
Yesterday, it surpassed 430K views!
On behalf of everyone who's been touched in sooth by your
attending good moments, vocals, bravo, and thank you.
Thank you!
What the heck?
Oh my gosh.
Wait, 4.30?
April 30th?
What the heck?
Oh my gosh.
Thank you so much, Darko.
Thank you.
And thank you, everybody, who's been listening to it.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
The prophecy.
430.
Bye.
It is pretty much 430, April 30th!
Oh my gosh!
Wait, my schedule of raising room ends in 29 hours?
Uh-oh.
Wait, I think I need to fix that.
Yay!
Let me do that then.
Tap, tap, tap, tap.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, you're right!
April 30th.
Oh, no, it's gonna end!
That's got to end!
Let it run out!
No, we'll do April 30th.
2027.
Save.
Acelon, do you have any last words?
Um.
Oh, what do you need?
What do you have to say?
I don't have to.
much going on today i'd really like to hang out with someone
oh he's bored let's give him some food we're gonna give him
his favorite thing ever which is chocolate gato yum yum and
then we'll end it imagine if this was actually his favorite
thing I... he didn't...
It's chocolate cake, Ocelot.
Is this how you guys feel when listening to Forever Meow?
Forever Meow.
I want to be forever Meow.
Do you really want to meow forever?
Ocel minto.
Oh, oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Bob Tokubi, thank you!
I was feeling it today.
I definitely need some silly stuff to lighten the mood.
Thanks for the good vibes.
It's why you're the best.
Thank you!
I hope you're feeling better!
See you guys!
Otsumi-to!
Otsumi-to-o-to-to-to-to-to-to-to-toe.
Etsumi-toe.
Have a good day, have a good night.
And...
What did it just say?
Oh, he said soy.
If I see you later for the collab, then I will see you later
for the collab.
Bye-bye!
Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye.
Sorry.
I do not have a POV, though.
So either watch Henya or Limu or POP.
Pinkney, thank you.
And Henya.
I'm so down in Middocks.
Oh my god.
Um...
Minto is leaving, it makes sense!
Hanya is on YouTube!
Pia Pia is on YouTube if you don't feel like watching on
Twitch.
So, actually, I will raid into Pia if it allows me.
I will raid into her waiting room.
If she has one up, actually, I don't know.
Thank you, everybody.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Oh.
Yeah.
I'll try for real this time.
Bye-bye.